all right
welcome everyone to lecture 13 of 1413.
this is my last lecture on social
preferences i hope all of you are
doing fine remotely hang in there i know
this is a very difficult time
this lecture is a bit of a more
uplifting lecture than the previous ones
well the previous ones have looked at
social preferences how we can measure
social preferences
and how can we perhaps isolate pure
altruism
do people really want others to be
better for their own sake
even if nobody knows about it either
others
or or whether there's no feedback um
we sort of found out that like it seems
like what looks a lot like
altruism people are nice to each other
it's not pure altruism in the sense that
like
they really want others to do well
instead
they want to either look good in front
of others or like you know they're
worried about reciprocity or sort of any
other negative feedback from others
or it might be they might want uh to
protect their self-image they want to
look good
in front of themselves and they try to
figure out ways to
um deceive themselves that they're nice
and if given the opportunity to not be
nice
people actually seem to be not as nice
as one might think from pure dictator
games or
ultimatum games that we observe this
lecture is a bit more
uplifting in the sense that it talks
about
field evidence on social preferences and
in particular
we're going to ask the question about
how can or can policies increase
pro-sociality in certain ways we're
going to talk about three broad
sets of studies first we're going to
talk about social preferences at the
workplace
i'm going to talk about the impact of
relative pay
on productivity we talked about this
last time at the end of the lecture a
little bit
but i'm going to just restart from
scratch to sort of explain that a little
bit better
then we're going to talk about the
morale effects of pay inequality
what happens to worker inequality when
people are paid
unequally and is that a good idea
there's also a very nice paper in ethnic
divisions and production in firms
we're going to talk about this a little
bit in recitation
number two we're going to talk about um
uh whether policies can
induce uh prosecutionality in particular
in a focus on mixing this is sort of the
called the contact hypothesis when you
mix people from different backgrounds
do they become nicer to each other in
various ways
um you know discuss a very nice paper by
gautam rao on mixing rich and poor
children in school they're going to talk
very briefly about mixing cricket
players
in india to reduce tensions across
castes or make people from different
casts
perhaps more pro-social to each other
i'm going to also briefly mention a
study on mixing roommates in college
by coronado finally we're going to talk
about
whether people perhaps underestimate the
benefits of prosociality
in particular i'm going to show you a
study on people undervaluing gratitude
so when people write letters of
gratitude do others
or do they understand how others might
react and
perhaps can be is there perhaps some
evidence that people
are not pro-social enough because they
misunderstand
the effects that that might have on
others
okay so let me
let me start with social preferences at
the workplace so
um bandaranadel is a very nice study
that looks at the impact of relative pay
on productivity
this is field evidence from a fruit farm
in the uk it's literally field evidence
because it's from fruit picking farms
from food fields
the study looks at two types of payment
schemes these are
piece rates workers are paid per unit of
output
and the second scheme is relative pay
workers are paid relative to others
we might sort of think that relative pay
is a good way to incentivize workers
because you know you want to do better
than
uh your neighbor and there's sort of a
competition
of who does best and in principle it
could be that like that really if you
only care about yourself that really
gets people to work very hard
now what bandiera now look at is like
does or how does the
introduction of relative pay affect
workers
effort and output now one thing they
notice is that
while um relative incentives might be
good because you might sort of
induce people to want to be better than
their um
their neighbors or their co-workers
there's also a negative
externality of relative pay that is the
idea that increasing
your own pay comes at the cost of others
pay
that is to say if there's relative pay
and i work really hard
i'm paid how i do relative to my friends
or others that i'm working with
well if i'm working really hard and do
better than my friends i'm going to be
paid more
but at the same time my friends for any
effort that i put in
my friends are going to be paid less and
so
workers sort of anticipating these
impacts on on others
might reduce their effort if they care
about others right if i'm really worried
about like if there's relative pay and i
work really hard my friends are going to
look bad
they're going to be relatively uh
unproductive
and i worry that they might not be paid
enough
then um i might reduce my effort and
sort of everybody might do that and then
the introduction of relative pay or the
relative pay schemes might actually not
be particularly
uh effective or effective way of
incentivizing
and motivating workers so there's sort
of this tension that relative pain
principle
could work quite well but if people
really care a lot about others
then it might not work at all it might
actually backfire in some ways
notice that it could be either that
people care about others
for their own sake in the sense that
like you might care about them
because you want them to have high
earnings or you might care about
others earnings not because you actually
care about the outcomes per se
but rather because you're worried about
negative repercussions right if these
are your friends and you worked really
hard
well at night your friends might really
not be happy and there might be sort of
retribution against you
socially or in some other ways if you
work too hard if you cause them
their earnings to go down okay
so now what does this paper do it looks
at how does switching to
to piece rates affect the people's
productivity um
so the study has personnel data from a
food farm in the uk
they measure productivity as a function
of their compensation scheme
this is a quasi-field experiment the
timeline is as follows
for the first eight weeks of the 2002
picking season
fruit pickers were compensated relative
on a relative performance scheme so um
uh
the per fruit piece the per piece rate
is decreasing in average productivity
right so like if everybody works really
hard and i don't if i'm relatively bad
compared to other i get less
than others the incentive to keep this
is sort of an incentive to keep as i
discussed
to keep the productivity low if you care
about others
and then in the next eight weeks
compensation was switched to a flat
piece rate per fruit
so that's essentially just like you're
paid by however you
how much you produce how many kilograms
of fruit you
collect and the payment is
entirely disjoint or independent of what
other peoples do that's like a classic
piece rate
payment so the externalities are
entirely shut down
if i work really hard i'm going to be
paid
there's no effect whatsoever on my
fellow workers
the switch was announced on the day the
change took place so it came as a
surprise to workers we so we should not
be worried about sort of
pre-trends or productivity going up over
time
anyway now what the people find is a
dramatic increase in productivity with
the introduction of piece rates
that is to say um what you see here in
the figure is
the average worker productivity for two
of the fields so this essentially like
broad big fields where people work on
i'm showing you sort of the data for two
of those fields for which essentially on
most days
there was actually production workers
were picking fruit
what you see on the left side of the
graph is um
when uh people were working under under
relative pay
there you see essentially relative flat
productivity
people had about like five kilograms
picked about five kilograms per hour
that doesn't seem to be any trend
upwards over time so before the new
policy was introduced essentially
workers were
producing um or picking their food at a
relatively constant rate over time about
five kilograms
per hour there was no trends as i said
now then you see so the vertical line um
in the middle
this is when um piece rates were in fact
um uh introduced so there was no
relative pay anymore and now they were
people were paid by piece rate
and that increased productivity by over
50 so workers became a lot more
productive
after that um that's true for both of
those
fields it is not the case that the
average
payment per unit of output per kilogram
uh
for people were paid were actually was
going up so you might sort of say well
you know if the piece rate was actually
higher
um under the piece rate payments
on the right side of the screen well
maybe then you know of the graph then
maybe workers would just be more
productive
but in fact if you look at sort of the
piece rate over time if anything the
piece rates actually went down over time
what the
company was paying so that is to say
the introduction of those piece rates
the productivity effect is not explained
by workers being paid more
per unit of output instead it seems to
be really coming from the different
incentives
people workers have when it comes to how
their productivity
affects their fellow workers on the
field
now you might have sort of like two
potential explanation here for this um
uh evidence one is social preferences so
you might work
less um to help others under relative um
uh incentives right and you might um
um even less when your friends benefits
you if you have many
uh friends on a certain field that work
with you
well then you might be particularly
inclined to not work very hard
because you will care a lot more um uh
for them
and this is sort of exactly what they
find in this paper uh these effects are
stronger when they're more
um friends on the field uh for a
particular worker
second however it's also like a repeated
game that is to say
the the sort of a low effort equilibrium
where essentially if there's relative
pay
we can just all agree everybody on the
field might sort of agree that not
working particularly hard
is uh is a good idea because we are
essentially paid relatively anyway
so if everybody doubles their effort
nothing is going to pay
there's nothing that's going to happen
to workers compensation
so you might as well just decide
everybody could just decide work half as
hard
and we're going to be paid the same and
as long as we sort of can
sustain at equilibrium that's a good
idea
of course in any given period
any given worker might have the
incentives to deviate from this
equilibrium
because on any given day if you work
really hard you're going to be paid a
lot more
for that today and so um
how might we be able to disentangle that
well um what bandiera
have is they have also some variation in
the types of fruits that
were collected what do i mean by that
well if you think about what you need to
be able to
disentangle these what you might want to
have is like differences in the
observability of effort right so if i
can
see what my co-worker does i can like
punish them very effectively i can just
know like whenever um
frank is working really hard my
co-workers might
want to punish me um and then it's very
hard for me to work really hard because
you know i'm getting trouble at night
after work with my co-workers or the
next day everybody might also work
really hard and i kind of don't want
that
on the other hand if i can hide how hard
i'm working well then you know
i might secretly work really hard and my
co-workers might not even
find out so then um if that's the case
in the repeated game um the repeated
game equilibrium might not just be
might just not be enforceable as in like
i might just tell my friends oh i wasn't
really working hard but in fact i was
and like
they have no way of finding out because
i was sort of
unobservable if instead i really care
about them if i'm really interested in
their
um in their well-being overall in their
payment
it doesn't matter whether my effort is
observable regardless of how observable
my effort is i will not work really very
hard because not working hard makes them
better off
so if you just had some differences in
observability
in effort how hard people work we could
just
disentangle these two um explanations
so um bandiera and i'll have this very
nice variation they have
two fruits they're fruit type one which
are strawberries
and they have fruit of type two which
are raspberries
if you ever have picked strawberries you
would know that
strawberries it's very easy these are
like essentially very flat
and low fruit that when somebody picks
strawberries it's very easy to see how
fast somebody works how much
anybody picks and so on because you can
just see across the entire field you can
see essentially what all of your
co-workers are doing
in contrast if you look at strawberries
sorry if you look at raspberries these
are bushes so you can essentially
literally hide behind the boat hide
behind the bushes and work really hard
to pick really hard
and fast without others noticing so
essentially productivity
is at least more unobserved than for
strawberries now what bundier at all
then find in fact is no impact of the
piece rate on fruits
of type type 2 which is raspberries
so that sort of suggests there is no
evidence of pure altruism
and the effects perhaps could be driven
by um
reciprocity this is kind of consistent
with what we had found before
when you remember the dictator ultimatum
games that we showed you
it looked a lot like people are
altruistic they care about others
but when you look at their actual
motives when you look at little when you
dig a little deeper we find out that in
fact
this is driven uh by reciprocity or by
worries about repeated game effects
or worries about essentially just
retribution either on the field that
you know other people will work also
really hard if i will work really hard
right now
or you know socially after work my
co-workers might be really mean to me
they might even beat me up or they might
not be my friends um anymore
and this is um um here so the regression
tables that show you this
the first column you see fruit type 2.
again these are the raspberries this is
when things are
unobserved there's no effect of
introducing the piece rate
in contrast if you look at column two
this is fruit type
one these are strawberries and there's
large productivity effects of
strawberries
there so these results again highlight
the importance of
setting the incentives carefully small
details matter and you really want to be
very careful and like how you said
relative incentives
that in principle seem like a good idea
because they sort of provide steep
incentives to workers
but in practice might actually not work
particularly well
okay so the second paper we're going to
look at is brazil these are the morale
effects of pay inequality
this is a very nice randomized field
experiment in rural india with lower
skill
manufacturing workers the question the
authors ask
is do workers care about relative pay
and perhaps why do we see so little
variation in pay across settings so what
we often see in many companies
in india but also in other places also
in
certain villages in india what we see is
wages tend to be very compressed
so workers essentially earn the exact
same wage
regardless of their um underlying
productivity
experience and so on good and bad
workers tend to work exactly
tend to earn exactly the same amount of
money
for per day or per hour and the like
economists think that's inefficient
because you know if you want to hire
somebody who's really really productive
you might want to hire pay them more
if you want to hire somebody who's not
that productive you might want to pay
them less
you might actually want to pay them less
than the prevailing wage
but you might not be able to do so
because the norm is that
you have to pay them the prevailing wage
and then you might end up
not hiring that person and that person
might end up being unemployed
even though it would you would be very
happy to to pay them at a lower wage
this is really a really relevant
question or sorry there's a second
question the authors ask is
what is the notion of the underlying
notion of fairness
what is kind of a fair and what's not
fair as in like
if there is wage dispersion across
workers
within teams or within a certain for our
firm are there some circumstances under
which that's okay to do are there some
good justification that workers are
uh okay with or in contrast
or uh is it just always bad to do so so
can we sort of find some situation on
which under which
uh it's justified for workers or not or
is it just like we cannot pay half pay
inequality under any circumstances
in those kinds of firms this is
potentially quite relevant for
many features of the labor market it
might explain
wage compression that's what i'm saying
like words tend to be fairly compressed
even if productivity is fairly dispersed
across workers
there tends to be lots of wage rigidity
wages tend to not move very much
it seems to be employers have trouble um
adjusting wages or they are reluctant to
adjust people's wages much in particular
when it comes to like downward rigidity
we talked about this a little bit
already
when we talked about reference
dependence um we can also think that
help this can help us think about like
sorting of workers into firms and
inequality
uh we can think about firm boundaries in
a sense to say like
should they be really large firms or a
number of small firms
if you think the relative comparison is
uh across workers within firms that
would sort of say well we should
probably
have a lot of small firms and then each
of these small firms could have
different wages
as opposed to like one large firm where
like essentially everybody has to be
paid more or less
the same and we might think that's
inefficient because there's returns to
scale of having like a large
um firm think about us that is also
relevant for some hr
policies in terms of like how do you pay
workers how do you set wages and so on
so as motivation in a study the authors
ask people the certain
the following questions the question is
the following
three this is rural india and rissa
a relatively poor area
with lots of small scale manufacturing
the question is three people from a
village get hired to work on a
construction site together
the prevailing wage is 250 rupees in the
village that's kind of the standard wage
in the village each village tends to
have like a prevailing weight which is
like how much people are paid usually
the contractor pays them uh 200 250
rupees per day
how well will they work together and
what you see is what respondents tend to
say is like 80 percent of respondents
say
uh uh people work very well together
uh 20 say as well as usual and zero
percent say there will be conflict so
that's kind of like seems like paying
everybody the same
is a socially acceptable thing to do
everybody seems happy
with that in contrast if you ask the
following which is the contractor pays
them different
wages if the contractor tractor pays 250
per day to 70 percent and put 290 per
day
how well will they work together
and so now um what you see here is when
there's differences
are cross pay 94 percent of workers
say there will be conflict now it
doesn't specify here at least in this
version of the question it doesn't
specify
whether that's to do with like
underlying productivity differences so
why is it that some workers are paid
different than others
however it's very strong suggestive
evidence that
workers might be really unhappy and
there will be conflict across workers
if they pay different wages in the same
kind of
team or at least on the same
construction site
and then okay of course if you're like
an employer you might be quite worried
about paying people different wages
because if there's conflict presumably
workers will not work
or collaborate as well as they could
potentially
okay so now the author set up a very
nice field experiment that looks like
this
so there's 10 production units of three
workers each
in each factory so think of factories
like work sites
factories and parenthood and quotation
marks because it's really not just a
factory as you might sort of imagine it
it's really like a small work site an
office where people are working in
different areas
there's 10 units of three workers each
so it's not a huge office
each unit of three workers produces
different products so like each unit has
like one
product for example unit one makes
brooms unit two makes
incense sticks union 3 makes
leaf plates and so on so each unit has
like one
item of production now why are the
different units is essentially to
separate workers into different lines of
work
so what we're going to expect is that
workers are going to compare each
other's
within unit but not so much across units
because if i make brooms and you make
instant sticks that's very different
work in some ways but if you make the
exact same thing the natural
comparison now for workers to compare
yourself with another worker
all unit members so everybody in a given
unit makes the exact same product so
everybody in unit
one who has like three workers makes
brooms
everybody in unit 2 makes incense sticks
and so on
now the key experimental variation in
the in the experiment
is wage dispersion across workers within
teams
finally there's uh also um and i'll get
back to that at the end production tasks
vary in their observability of uh
performance
so that is to say for some tasks it just
happens to be that it's
much easier to understand how productive
your co-worker is than in other
tasks okay so now what is the
variation in relative pay so here you
see um
[Music]
people are paid depending on their
worker rank
there's four different regimes of pay in
the different columns
heterogeneous compressed l compressed m
and compress
h workers are sorted so there's a
baseline period where workers are worked
for a few days
and a few days are used to assess their
baseline productivity
they're ranked into three tertiles
so there's like the low productive
workers medium productivity and high
productivity workers
they're ranked essentially based on how
well they did at baseline
okay so if you're like really bad to
start with you would be a low
productivity worker if you're like an
average worker it would be medium
productivity
and if you're really like highly
productive worker you would be
classified as
high productivity workers notice that's
always done for all of the different
treatment groups
the difference now is across these
different
regimes how workers are paid in the
heterogeneous pay essentially there's
differences in
um across workers in the sense that like
uh the low productivity workers are paid
the low wage the median productivity pay
workers are paid a medium wage and the
high productivity workers are paid a
high wage
as you might expect that's sort of the
natural thing to do in terms of you want
to reward productivity
the most productive workers you're going
to pay
the most notice that these wage
differences are modest so even like the
difference between
a w high and w uh low are like uh
uh uh only about like up to 10
so really these are not huge differences
it's not that the other guy if you are
like a little productivity worker
or if you get wlo it's not the other guy
gets like twice as much it really is
like modestly more
but it is more money that they get now
then
if you look at the other three regimes
compressed l compressed m compressed age
low productivity so in compressed l
everybody gets the low wage and
compressed m
everybody gets the medium wage and
compressed age
everybody gets the high wage now the
study now lets the authors compare
the different columns for holding
exactly constant baseline productivity
and wage levels
that is to say for instance we can
compare the
heterogeneous low the low productivity
workers that happen to be randomized
into like the heterogeneous treatments
they receive wlo or uh compare them with
like low productivity workers at
baseline who happen to be randomized
into a compressed l
so i should have said more clearly
people are randomized into any of these
four groups
and then depending on what your baseline
productivity is you get the wages as i
show here
in the table so for example if you're
like a low productivity worker you might
be
randomized into the heterogeneous
treatment
group you might receive w low or you
might be randomized into the
low compressed load treatment
where you also receive wlo notice that
your
in both cases that worker is a low
productivity worker
uh in both cases the worker receives w
low
however what's different here now is
that his co-worker his or her i think
his in this case these are men
co-workers are receiving either the same
which is in compressed l
or they receive higher wages uh in the
heterogeneous wage treatment
right so now we can look at like workers
who have the exact same baseline
productivity on average at least
and have the exact same wage but what's
being varied is like how much other
workers are earning
we can do this for low productivity
workers we can also do it for medium
productivity workers or
also for high productivity workers i
skipped the medium productivity worker
but that's exactly the same
for high productivity workers we can
look at the workers who
have been randomized into the
heterogeneous treatment uh group or
hedonist worker group
uh sorry heterogeneous wage group where
um the worker gets a wh but everybody
else gets like a lower wage or we can
compare that to
a compressed age where everybody gets
wh in that group
okay so now what do you what do the
authors find let's start with the
low productivity workers at baseline
remember the clean comparison here is
between
pay disparity this is the heterogeneous
group pay disparity and compressed l
which is like the group where everybody
has paid
the same now what the authors find and
you see this in the graph
fairly nicely which is like the
productivities are like the red line and
the blue line the productivity on the
left side this is before the treatment
starts
for about over 10 days the productivity
looks pretty much
the same but then when you go to the
right side of the graph
not immediately but after a few days
there seem to be
a gap or a gap emerges between the red
line and the blue line which is exactly
the gap as you would expect
if pay disperse the disparity
makes workers less productive which is
to say
they're workers who receive a low wage
but others in their group are receiving
higher wages are becoming
less productive compared to workers
that receive a low wage where others
have the exact same
productivity and you see this also in
the regression tables you see about a 22
percent
reduction in mean outputs and a 9
reduction in in earnings which are
pretty large effects so these are like
large effects compared to like other
interventions that people have
tried interesting and you see a little
bit like um
well the treatment effect when you look
at the graph initially looks not
particularly large
if anything it's this might not even be
there after like a few days
that treatment effect increases over
time it becomes larger so
over time people become less and less
productive compared to the
compressed wage treatment interestingly
we find or the authors find
similar effects for high rank high
productivity workers
so notice that these are now workers who
either who are
high productivity workers they receive
the same wage in the pay disparity
treatment and the compressed age
treatment
that have the same wage in one case they
are
paid exactly the same in the other case
they are paid
more compared to their co-workers and
what happens to me or what seems to be
the case is that
the compressed um high-pay workers
they're in fact
more productive compared to others you
might have expected in some ways like if
one guy
gets paid high payment and others get
paid less that makes the high pay worker
more productive because maybe he feels
good about himself that he's the high
pay workers or maybe he feels like you
prove himself or the like
but instead what seems to be the case
the group that works um
in his team does not work well together
or they just
becomes uncomfortable to work with like
somebody else who is like really mad at
you for earning more
than they do and so now the high
pay workers in the compressed treatment
in fact earn more
or produce more than the uh high pay
workers
in the pay disparity treatment so that
is to say the
pay disparity or pain equality
does not only reduce uh workers
productivity for the low pay workers so
not only the people who
work the workers who are earning less
compared to their coworkers
and that's in some sense to be expected
you might just be mad that everybody
else or other people in your group
are earning more then you might be
unhappy and mad about that and just then
produce
less instead it seems to be the case
even the high productivity workers the
workers who are
earn more than others in their group are
producing
less compared to the control group where
everybody earns the
same so what do we learn from that well
pay disparity lowers work
performance for all team members um
and so the interpretation of that is
that that pay uh disparity
undermines workers ability to cooperate
cooperate in their own
self-interests um the the paper has some
additional evidence with some
cooperative tasks
where essentially workers are worse at
cooperating with each other
it seems to really be that workers are
not happy
to work in the same place with somebody
else who
earns less importantly the perceived
justification
is essential in mediating these effects
that is to say i told you previously
that for some tasks it was easier to
see who's more productive than others
especially at baseline just because in
the task you know the differences across
highly and less highly productive or
lower high and low productivity workers
was just wider and it's just easy to see
that
frank is really bad at this and somebody
else is really good and for some tasks
it's really easy to see that
for others not so if it's really easy if
there's a perceived justification
for workers if workers sort of thought
okay it's really easy to see who is more
productive than others
the effects are much weaker than when
there is no perceived justification
that is to say workers themselves are
saying like if i'm saying like look
there's this other worker who's really
productive
and if i'm sort of saying like hey look
this is really obvious that they're more
productive than i am
it's only fair that they're earning more
then
these effects are much damp and there's
much less in fact it's it's accepted
and there's much less of a productivity
effect if any
uh if there's pay inequality however if
it seems to be the case that we're kind
of like producing the same thing
if um and we're like similar sorry we're
producing the same thing and we're
equally good at it or approximately
equally good
and one person is paid more than i am
for no good reason
so it appears then workers are really
not happy about that
and work performance in particular
output
falls so what are the implications well
this evidence sort of suggests that wage
compression um
may be more likely in some settings than
in others right that's to say like
if it's easy to justify if the
production function or like the
production process is such that all
aspects of the production and the output
or the performance are easy measurable
measurable and observable for workers
then you know workers might say
it's okay if some workers are earning
more than others
however if that's not the case if
there's a bunch of stuff in the work
process that's really not observed maybe
it's verbal or maybe it's just really
hard to justify or hard to sort of
assess in some
tangible way then you know workers might
be really unhappy
and that might lead to wage compression
because the employer might anticipate
um that so overall that sort of says
that like
um relative comparisons matter quite a
bit
fairness matters quite a bit and what's
really key for an employer or anybody
who sets incentives
is to take into account these fairness
consideration
rations and one wants to really
understand what is fair and what is not
and upsetting workers by violating these
fairness considerations or norms
might be really really costly for an
employer
so the good news here is that like if
one understands that well you know one
can really sort of produce
increase productivity quite a bit and in
some cases
wage inequality is actually fine one
just has to be careful in figuring out
when exactly is that the case
okay as i said there's a very nice paper
by
jonah stewart on ethnic divisions and
production and firms
we're going to talk about that in
recitation
okay the second part of this lecture
we'll talk about
policies to increase pro-sociality
and so uh the first of these papers is a
very nice recent paper by gautam rao
that looks at the question are social
preferences malleable
like what are the origins of social
preferences why is it that some people
appear nicer
than others and then you know once we
understand that perhaps we can also
understand what policies of anything
anything can affect social preferences
the main question that this paper asks
is how does being mixed with poor
student in school affect the social
preferences of
rich students now in a lot of
kind of policies where poor students are
mixed with rich students
you might ask the question how does it
affect the poor student if a poor
student for whatever reason
would not be able to afford like a rich
school or a rich student school
and you sort of allow them by giving
them scholarships or other policies
uh uh often the question that people ask
is like what are the benefits
of doing that is this a poor student uh
you know doing better in school or do
they have different types of friends
different networks and does that lead to
better jobs and so on and so forth
this question this paper asked a
different question and asked the
question about
what is the effect of rich students if
they randomly or quasi-randomly are
exposed to
uh being in class with additional or
some more poor students um the paper
exploits a policy change that um
introduced an admissions quota of 20 for
poor students in primary schools
in in delhi delhi these are like rich
private um primary schools the paper
looks at two sources of variation
there's variation across classrooms that
allows the author to look at the overall
effects so you can look at like
within schools there's going to be like
treated um uh
uh uh uncontrolled courts because the
policy was introduced
uh at some point so for um some students
uh uh they enjoyed the benefit of being
in class with
with poor students or the costs we'll
see about that
and for other schools they're already
too far advanced they were like
essentially before the pod they went to
school before the policy was enacted
and therefore um they were not exposed
to having poor
uh students in in school for for these
treated schools there's essentially
variation within school across cohorts
um that we can look at look at um
second within cohorts we can look at
treated and uh
control schools so some schools were
getting
additional poor kids and others did not
i'll tell you about this in a second
and then there's variation within
classrooms to allow us to look at
the role of personal interactions that
sort of idiosyncratic assignments to
study groups
so some students happen to be in study
groups with a poor kid and others
were not
now what does the study measure the
study measures three broad set of
outcomes
it matters pro-social behavior and
generosity this is very much what we
have already looked at
in particular it looks at dictator games
and voluntary volunteering
for charities at school the paper has a
very nice
mix of laboratory outcomes sort of
measured in the field which is sort of
the dictator games that you're all
familiar with
and field outcomes which is sort of
trying to
collect real-world outcomes in the sense
of like things that are perhaps somewhat
less contrived
from the perspective of like kids in
school and
what's very nice about the study is that
it seems to be that the results are very
much aligned
between sort of these lab outcomes the
dictator game type outcomes
and the field outcomes for just
volunteering for charity at school in
this case
second the author looks at
discrimination and social interactions
in particular he does a little sports
contest and looks at teammate selection
among these students and then
willingness to attend play dates with
poor students finally the author also
looks at academic outcomes in particular
test scores and disciplinary infractions
now why might one want to look at
academic outcomes and why are we
interested in social preferences
there's several reasons for that in
particular an important reason here is
that
um uh if you're against this type of
policy i might sort of show you that
oh you know adding poor children um uh
might affect the the social preference
of rich children and so on in various
ways maybe discrimination goes down but
perhaps it's the case that that all
comes at the cost of academic
performance
but if you're trying to sort of
implement this policy and uh
you know persuade policy makers maybe
teachers
um or parents of like okay let's have
more
poor students in in in in your school
well parents might sort of be okay fine
there's going to be like some change in
social preferences
some change in discrimination but really
what we care about is um
uh test scores or um discipline at
school and these poor kids might not be
um might be worse in terms of like test
scores
and they might have like negative peer
effects in terms of like
um a test scores but also in terms of
disciplinary
infractions and sort of as a policy
question then it's really important to
understand
if there are some benefits in terms of
pro-sociality or
reduced discrimination do these benefits
come at the cost of
reduced academic performance
okay so now what is in fact the policy
innovation in delhi in 2007
there was a 20 admissions quota in
private schools introduced
for poor students in some of these
private schools there's a household
income
cut off of two thousand dollars per year
so these are not sort of the poorest of
the poor of the students
who who are qualified
schools which received subsidy
subsidized land from the government um
were essentially um uh uh uh included in
this policy change
that's over 90 of elite private schools
so think of these elite private schools
these are really sort of like
very rich kids or parents
of these kids there was no fees for the
poor kids because you know they would
not be able to afford these fees anyway
there was importantly also no tracking
so it wasn't that like
a high ability or high performance kids
who do very well
were like tracked in the lake high
tracks and the good good tracks versus
lower tracks
instead everybody was mixed together
poor and rich high performing low
performing
students and the poor kids were selected
using lotteries
which in principle also allows the
author or others to look at
the effect on those poor kids the
students who are selected versus not
to be clear this is not the subject of
this paper
just to give you a sense of the
magnitude of like the
uh uh the mixing you see i said um
uh the average beneficiary um uh was
sort of at the 25th um
uh percentile of the uh income
distribution in in
in in delhi uh and wealthy students are
very much on the
um on the right tail
sorry on the right tail of the
distribution uh
something like the 90th percentile 95th
percentile which is about
the west equivalent of that would be
about two hundred thousand dollars um
per year
the average um uh beneficiary had like a
u.s equivalent income of
like 23 000 again these are not the
poorest of the poor but relatively poor
as about like an order of magnitude
poorer than the average person in the
actual school
now this policy then induced large
variation
across classrooms you look at
poor students in the fraction of for the
number so you have poor students
in by grade in 2011. i told you this
the policy innovation was in 2007. so if
you look in 2011 that's four years
later anybody who is in
grade four in 2011 has essentially
no poor student in their class in those
rich
schools so for students who are in 2011
and grade four
five or six that policy came too late
they do not have any
poor classmates in contrast if you look
at
the lower grades grades three two one
and zero which are essentially uh
preschool or zero minus one which is
preschool grades
uh there's lots of additional poor
students now
uh in those uh uh rich schools
now again uh there's variation within
schools and across schools the variation
within schools is across classrooms
that's kind of what i'm showing you
um here um but there's also variation
uh across schools so just to be clear
the variation within schools
across classrooms is like in the treated
schools
um there's some classes like the fourth
grade
have like essentially zero poor kids in
their classes
and uh the third grade in contrast
have um lots of poor poor kids
in the classroom we can do that
comparison uh across classrooms within
school
in addition there's also variation
across schools there's in particular
there's treatment schools
um which comply in 2007 as they were
supposed to
but then there's also delayed treatment
schools which complied in 2008
so the jump shifted by one quart so the
court the jump that i showed you here
um this is for the treatment schools
that
complied uh or this is for everybody
that complied in 2007
the delayed one complete a year later so
you see them essentially
somewhat later um uh increasing or one
year later exactly
increasing the fraction of poor kids in
their classroom and then there's the
control schools they were not subject to
the policy at least until 2013
so they had received
they had received land from federal
government or private foundations
so essentially there was no treatment uh
that is all students are rich in these
types of classes
so that was the the land receiving is
essentially just uh that was like a
fairly arbitrary rule in some ways uh so
that sort of leads to
at least quasi-random variation and some
schools uh received
the treatment and others um did not
um now let me show you some outcomes so
one outcome is our friend the dictator
game which you've seen quite a bit and
played already
as well is students are allowed with 10
rupees
which is you know not very much that's
about like 15 um
cents and they choose to share um notice
that these are
pretty pretty young kids so 10 rupees is
quite a bit of money for them they
choose to share
an amount as before between 0 and 10.
and
i got them sets this up such that
students could it was not just about the
money but they also can exchange the
money for candy later
add one rupee per piece so that was a
pretty um good deal
then um the dictator games for the order
was randomized the
kids would play two games again these
are all rich kids who do that
they play first game one where the
recipient is a poor student in a school
for poor children
and in game two it's a rich student in a
private control school
notice it's a control school to be clear
so it's not a kid that they might know
so the kids are
chosen such that the kids were
given the names and the photographs of
the school shown to the subject to the
kids
so you could sort of see and this is
verified in the briefing by the author
is that the the the children understand
very well
who's a rich kid and who's a poor kid um
but these are not kids that they would
actually know
and something that's a less interesting
question if you have gone
to school with somebody for a long time
you might have seen them around
in your schoolyard you might be nicer to
them or less nice to them
that's not what the study is looking at
the study is looking at
other kids in other schools that look
rich
or look poor um both in terms of like
the way um
uh uh they're dressed and so on but in
particular the way their school
looks like so essentially these are now
we're looking at social preferences
towards
other people people that these kids
don't know
okay so now what do we see so this is
the generosity
to the poor so like this is essentially
the results from game number one
again remember these are all um rich
kids who are giving now to poor kids and
the question now is
is being exposed to or does being
exposed to poor children
um uh uh uh for several years
does that affect um uh giving
uh in the form of dictator games
towards poor children to start with
we're going to talk about rich students
after that so here you see the
generosity to the poor and controlled
schools
you see this is the percent given to the
poor recipient
it's remarkably similar to what we've
seen previously which is about 28 or 30
percent about 25
is given to the poor uh kid in the
control groups
uh in the control schools um this
fraction
trend seems to trend up a little bit
over time but it's also quite constant
over time across grades you see here
grades two
three four and five on the x-axis and
the y-axis is the percent given to the
poor recipients
now adding the treatment schools now we
find uh
that for two grades for grade two and
grade three
remember the graph that i showed you
here you see that
in grades three two one and so on these
are the kids who are exposed
to the poor children in class in
contrast to grades four and five that
have not been exposed to poor kids in
their class
so what this graph note shows is that
exactly the grades
three and two that have been exposed in
the treatment groups that have been
exposed to poor classmates
these are exactly the students the
grades where
giving is higher um
[Music]
towards the poor compared to the control
groups
but also compared to the older cohorts
four and five the grade four and five
when you look at grades four and five
there you see essentially no difference
between treatment and control schools
so they seem to be very similar in
contrast if you look at
grades three and through where the
treatment uh kids are
exposed to the treatment by having the
poor kids in their classrooms
these are exactly the years where um
giving goes up and goes up by quite a
bit well the average
was as i said before about 25 that goes
up to about 35
so that's a pretty large relative
increase
now in addition um as i told you there
are also delayed treatment groups
uh treatment schools so for those
schools if you were in grade three
it was also too late for you because the
treatment was introduced only a year
later
so if you were in grade 3 you did not
have any
poor kids in your school now if you look
at the yellow line here the yellow line
looks very much like the green line
that is for the delayed treatment
schools there's no impact
either they look very much like the
control group schools
as you would expect however
in the late treatment schools in grade
number two
that's the grade where um the students
are exposed
the rich students are exposed to the
poor kids you will see essentially
similar effects
to the treatment schools as you expect
so that's fairly compelling evidence
that really
the differences that you see across
these schools
are driven by the treatment
that was on the timing of the treatment
as opposed to
other potential effects due to like you
know selection or maybe these schools
are different and so on
we see essentially no differences in
grades four and five for
any of the treatment and control schools
you also
see no difference in grade three for the
delayed
treatment schools compared to the
control group in contrast
we see clear differences in grade two
for the delayed treatment schools
compared to the control schools
we also see a clear difference for the
treatment schools compared to both
the control schools and the delayed
treatment schools
as well so that's fairly compelling
compelling evidence that
game or play in dictator games changes
when students are exposed for quite a
long time to poor kids in their
classroom
okay so now in addition um
we will have a variation within a
classroom so what i show you here this
is all variation
across classrooms that is to say if you
have a poor kid in your classroom
you will behave differently um or that
will change your attitudes or you're
giving in
in dictator games uh towards
the poor or other poor or children now
in addition
um the author also has um
[Music]
evidence of variation within classroom
they let you think about for a second
why is it important to also have
variation within classroom
isn't the evidence that we have here
already compelling enough why do we need
more
and you think about this for a second
the reason for that is that the diff and
if the difference in differences
comparing essentially across
classrooms identifies the overall effect
of having poor classmates in class
that might be the result of like
personal interactions
but it might also be the result of like
the teacher uh the curriculum might
change your parents might change
in some ways and just telling you like
look there's these poor kids in your
class
the teachers might tell everybody oh you
need to be nice to poor kids
the curriculum might change it might
sort of include things that tell you to
be nice to poor kids and so on you might
be sort of exposed to just different
types of material
so really given the evidence that we
have here when you just compare across
classrooms
you cannot disentangle whether this is
driven from like
being personally um exposed in terms of
interacting with poor children
personally by just talking to them in
certain ways and being exposed to them
and like
learning about them and so on so it
cannot disentangle personal interactions
from teacher curriculum changes that are
essentially at the classroom level
so in addition then gautam also has
within classroom within classroom
strategy
that uh exploits the assignment to study
groups
what is that doing is essentially it
isolates the role of direct
personal interactions and is not subject
to sorting concerns another concern
might be that
you know you might sort of say oh oh in
this school
uh uh uh they're having like poor kids
that
um uh that are led into this private
school
i'm gonna send my kids to somebody else
so that's also an issue
perhaps potentially in the uh uh
in the evidence that i showed you before
across classrooms that within classroom
strategy is now looking at
everybody who's in that classroom and
looking at some kids where they're just
randomly assigned to be in study groups
with poor kids and others were not
and that sort of allows to disentangle
or allow us to isolate the
effect of personal interactions so one
hour a day
um kids were working in small groups of
two to four students
remember this is for a very long period
of time so like you know
um it's one hour per day but it was also
like for quite a bit of time it's not
just like doing that once or twice it's
for like an extended period of time
and crucially some schools use the
alphabetic order of first names to
assign
study groups so that's essentially
exogenous variation in personal
interactions
other schools frequently um
shuffled the groups and only um which
essentially
sort of uh everybody was equally exposed
to those kinds of
uh uh to two different students to your
sometimes in study groups with
rich students only and sometimes for
poor students only
in the first group where the alphabetic
order was used
you were either sort of in the study
group where you happened to be
next to somebody um
uh uh who's a poor kid because they
happen to be next to you in the alphabet
or you're not and that stayed the same
now
what does this let us look at
essentially the alphabetic order
predicts
um study partners so now you might say
people with different names might also
be different so it could just be that
like my name
because my name is different i'm more
likely to be
next in the alphabet to a poor student
for example if i'm a rich kid and
there's some
names that are like more similar to poor
kids names
it could be that my parents are
particularly tolerant they also gave me
a name that
sounds like a poor person and therefore
i'm more likely to be in a study group
with a poor
other poor kid it's not and that's not
then the impact of being in the study
group but rather sort of selection just
could be that
names are different or people with
different names are different so that's
why having this control group is really
nice
so what we can look at now is to say we
can look at
kids that have names adjacent to rich
students and kids that have names
adjacent to
poor students so if you look at the left
side is essentially looking at
students that have their names adjacent
to
rich students only or students that have
names adjacent to also some poor
students
when you look at that where the
alphabetic order was not used
the outcome here is now what's your
share of having poor study partners and
so there essentially there's no
difference
as it should be because the alphabetic
order was not used they were just
shuffling around
the kids all the time so it didn't
really matter what your alphabet was it
didn't really matter but
but crucially we can still look at the
alphabet we can look at
kids that have names where adjacent in
the alphabet there's only
rich kids rich students or we can look
at
kids that have names where adjacent to
the alphabets they're poor students
and here you see on the left side of the
graph you see essentially no difference
across these
groups so they were equally likely to
have a poor kid in their study group
in contrast on the right side of the
graph you see
the alphabetic order was used to assign
study groups so if you had a name
adjacent
to a poor student in the alphabet you're
very very likely to have a poor kid
assigned to you or be in your study
group not always because you know
sometimes these are groups of three so
that sometimes you were
lucky or unlucky depending on how you
view it there were just sort of the
group was like just above you or below
you in the alphabet
but most of the time if you have a name
adjacent to approach student that
student or any
uh any poor student would be in your
study group
uh if you didn't have a name adjacent to
you um
or if you only had like rich student
adjacent to you there's still a chance
that you have a poor student in your
study group because this could be just
like you know not the person next to you
but the person
another person further down is in fact a
poor student you end up in that group
without
that student remember these are groups
of two to four students
so it could just be that you're in a
group of three to four student and not
the person adjacent to you but the
person after that
ends up in your study group so you're
still likely to have
um or you know you have still like about
like a 40
chance of having a poor kid in your um
in your study group but there's a huge
difference between the two types of
groups
um the name adjacent to the study group
has like huge fraction about 90
or uh versus 40 so crucially now we can
compare
for both types of schools for the
schools on the right-hand side
where essentially the names are very
predictive of
of having a poorest kid in uh in your
study group
versus on the left-hand side where the
names are not predictive at all whether
um you have a a poor kid in your study
group
and so we can like that way we can keep
selection the same the types of name are
the same
we are isolating the impact of having a
poor kid
in your study group now what does the
author find he finds that
this is what we showed you before which
is about you know
in the control group we had about uh in
the dictator game
these kids gave about 27 um
uh 27 percent uh being having a poor kid
in your classroom that's the evidence
that i already showed you the treatment
effect is about
uh uh 12 percentage points that's fairly
large that's almost like a 50
a 50 increase a little bit less than
that so that's a huge
increase and then in addition um when
you look at
kids that have a poor study partner
notice that these are things not
necessarily additive but you have a poor
study partner versus not
there's an effect of about 7.5
percentage points
that's a pretty large effect so
both of these things seem to matter
personal interactions seem to be quite
important
but in addition there seem to be also
some additional effects perhaps coming
from the
classroom level you might so there's two
types of effects that are possible here
some types of effects could be from the
teacher parents curriculum etc might be
different
or other things could be just like even
if you don't have a poor kid in your
study group you might still play with
them or be friends with them or just
seeing them around a new classroom
might affect you but crucially crucially
the
personal interactions seem to be very
important
as well now one question you might ask
as well so far i showed you generosity
towards
poor children right so that was game
number one we looked at
what happens in the dictator games when
a rich kid
plays with a poor kid and the rich kids
become nicer towards the
poor kids now how about generosity
towards
other wealthy children well it turns out
that that that increases as well
there's a smaller effect size but it's
still substantial and in fact um
statistically uh significant
so why might that be you might sort of
ask well what's going on here
so here's the the evidence you sort of
see the
changing giving to rich participants
this is sort of like a distribution you
see
this is the share giving to the rich
participant it seems to be what happens
these are essentially the fraction of
students in the different treatment
versus control
who gives 0 10 20 30 40 50 percent
and what you see there's about a 10 um
percentage points
decrease in the fraction who gives zero
and about uh eight something uh
percentage points increase in the
fraction who give
fifty percent so it seems to be that
there's quite a few students
who move from zero um percent about like
you know ten percent of them move from
zero percent
to um uh 50 and 50 50 is kind of like
the equal
allocation so rich kids are also
becoming nicer towards
rich kids in these dictator games so
what's going on here
um there's different potential
explanations perhaps the most
plausible explanation the study you know
has some evidence on that
um at the end of the day it's hard to
sort of entirely nail this or like you
know
rule out all other potential explanation
but it's quite
plausible that what's happening here is
that like inequity
students when you're exposed to poor
children you're essentially
um more averse to like inequality
or inequity across people
even in things in fairly trivial things
that are such as
dictator games now i told you before
that's a little bit
funny because dictator games obviously
are very narrowly framing people and
looking at essentially
when very narrow outcomes um
if we have like a 50 50 outcome in the
dictator game that doesn't mean that our
life is
uh the same it might be you might be
still much richer than i am
so um having sort of equal outcomes in
the dictator game 50 50 allocation in
the dictator game
might be narrowly framed in that
particular game fair but of course it's
not fair in the grand scheme of things
but what seems to be the case is that um
and there's some evidence other evidence
in the paper that you can read if you
would like
it seems to be the case that um rich
children become more averse to unequal
outcomes in the world in general because
they essentially see
these poor kids who who are very smart
and you know um
are disadvantaged in terms of various
ways from like having
a lower wealth of their parents the rich
kids become sort of more averse against
that
and that translates even into like
dictator games with
other rich kids um in a very sort of
minor thing in the world in in these
dictator games
again even though the dictator games
actually don't change very much but they
really seem to be
averse to an equality of these outcomes
and move them from the 10-0 allocation
to
50-50 even with these rich kids
okay so that was like evidence on social
preferences as measured by dictator
games
the paper also has some evidence on
discrimination in particular a small
field experiment on team selection
so um what does the study do so the
subjects
are again students from two elite
private schools so now it's like two of
these
selected student schools are selected
one is a treatment school
one is a control group and in addition
gautam invited athletic poor students
from a public school
importantly these are athletic students
these are students who are better at
sports than
the rich kids you might think you know
the poorer kids are better at sports
than the rich kids anyway which is
probably true
but now these are particularly athletic
students on purpose
who are invited to attend a sports event
as well
now students in this in this experiment
in this game must
choose teammates to run a relay race now
when you know a rich kid who who is
thinking about who
who who should be in my team you can
either choose like a rich kid
who is kind of like similar to you and
uh
in social ways or or you can choose a
poor kid
who whom you don't know very much you
might actually not like the poor kids
but you know the poor kid is a lot
better in the in the running
um so it might be like much better for
you might be much more likely to win in
the game
because now your partner in the relay
race is much faster so it's a very nice
trade-off between ability
choosing uh the fast runner versus
social similarity
and now what what um uh gotten then is
doing is like he uh if you sort of
choose the rich kid
that's then a measure of discrimination
because essentially
you're choosing a worse runner um
in favor of like um or because you want
more social similarity
you don't want to hang out with a poor
kid instead you choose the rich kid
which reduces your chances in the race
but increases your time
spent with the rich kids compared to
like poor kids
let me tell you a little bit more detail
of the experiment
uh stage one is randomization so it was
the
the people were randomized to sessions
with varying stakes
there's uh 50 50 rupees 20 200 rupees
500 rupees per
uh student for the winning team this is
a lot of money compared to like students
usual pocket money right so they would
get something like 10
or 500 rupees um is like one months of
uh pocket money that's like really high
stakes for these kids
um the price is varied essentially
because it lets us like price out it
gives us a price of discrimination
lets us understand how much are students
willing to give up in order
um uh to not have to um or
in order to uh be able to socialize with
the rich kids compared to a poor kid
there was brief mixing to start with to
judge socio-economic status
right so the kids were like allowed to
mingle a little bit that would allow
them to
fairly easily understand who's a poor
kid and who's a
rich kid okay stage number two was
ability revelation and team selection so
you could essentially observe a
two-person race
usually it's one poor and one rich
students neither is from their own
schools so these are not
students that you would know from school
anyway
but the uniforms make the school
identifiable do you kind of know who's
the rich kid and who's the poor kid
now then you can pick which of these two
runners you want to have as your
partners
so that is to say you see them run
one by one it's very easy to see like
who's faster and who's not
and so again discrimination here is um
uh
interpreted as like picking the slow
runner so if you pick the slower runner
and then it must be because you like
something
some other characteristics about that
person more the obvious characteristic
here is that
it's most likely going to be that kid is
rich
okay then um uh
stages three and four are on the choice
implementation
relay race so students are randomly
picked to have their choices implemented
so some of those choices
this is again the strategy method some
of these choices were actually randomly
implemented
so there's plausible deniability for um
the students in the sense of like you
could just uh
you know you could just happen to be um
randomized or
you you happen to pick some students
versus another uh
could just be by chance that you are
with one student versus another
so you couldn't you're free to choose
essentially provides you cover sometimes
as we discussed before
the computer is choosing so you always
have an excuse so it's intended
to reveal students true preferences as
opposed to
perhaps what they think that their
friends want them to choose or uh
the other runners then the relay races
were actually held and prices were
distributed as promised
number four crucially there was a social
interaction
so if you picked like your teammate you
actually have to spend two hours of
playing with a teammate
board games sports playgrounds and so on
importantly this was pre-announced
so now again as i said before when
picking your partner
you have the choice between either
picking the fast
poor kid which will really increase your
probability of winning
um or the rich kid who's kind of slow
and will reduce your uh reduce your
probability of winning
but if you pick that poor kid or the
rich kid you have to actually spend
two hours with that teammate playing
board game sports playground and so on
and you might not want to do that with a
poor kit
okay so now first you know what is
demand for um
discrimination you can look at this
graph it shows very nicely
for the different prices as i said 500
rupees for winning the rice
200 rupees or 500 rupees if you look at
500 rupees this is again one month of
pocket money
there's no difference between treated
and untreated classrooms
that is to say so there's ten percent of
people
are um as you want discriminating the
poor so ten percent or sorry
this is less than ten percent is about
um seven eight percent of students
um pick the rich kids um even in the
really really high stakes
race that is to say when the stakes are
500 rupees
they're like about six seven eight
percent of students
who still pick the rich kid um and they
sort of take into account
the the um uh the chance that they that
that might lose them the raise
but um you know they don't have to spend
two hours um
uh with a poor kid than socializing now
when you look at the lower prices
the fraction as you expect this is the
red line um
sorry this is the green line the upper
line the fraction would choose
the rich kids the fraction who are
discriminating against the poor
increases
as you expect so now it becomes cheaper
it's only like the race is only 200
rupees or 50 rupees
you might be more inclined to pick the
rich kid because you know the value of
socializing stays the same
but the cost of picking the regicate the
cost of losing the race
potentially at least is reduced right
the and sort of if you look at 50 rupees
the price 50 rupees um for the game
for the relay race uh uh that's um
about almost like 40 percent of students
now pick the rich kid
even though that might lose them the
race and now crucially
in red this is the dashed line below you
can see the treated classrooms
and what he finds is that for 500 rupees
when the stakes are really really high
there's no effect essentially it doesn't
really matter whether you're in a
treated or
non-treated classroom in part perhaps
because there's not much room for
going lower than that so essentially
there's no effect on
on there because you know the stakes are
really really high anyway there's not
much discrimination
and having had a treated class having
had a poor kid in your classroom doesn't
really
change that but then very clearly for
200 rupees and 50 rupees the lower
stakes there's a clear difference
between the green and the red lines that
is to say there's a lot less
discrimination
towards the poor kids poor kids a lot
more likely to be chosen
when a student had in treated classrooms
when somebody had a poor kid another
poor kid
in their classroom for several years so
that's to say
there's being exposed to these poor
children reduces discrimination
among the poor among the rich students
uh subsequently
um this is the sort of the same graph
that i showed you before
again that's sort of consistent with
what we have before it gets a little
messier than we had seen previously
but similarly even within classrooms uh
if you look at like grades two and three
versus four and five
uh uh the effects seem to be uh
concentrated more pronouns
in grades uh two and three
now finally as i said we
we look at test scores and discipline so
arguably there are some positive effects
on social preferences and
as i said before the policy question now
is does that come
at the cost of academic achievement in
some ways so is it that your rich kid
now by being exposed to the poor kids
maybe
somewhat nicer and more friendly and
less discriminating against the poor
um that's all and good but is it the
case now that cloud that um
test scores go down so gautam finds no
effect on aggregate
uh an aggregate test score index there's
zero effects on hindi and math
there's a little bit of like um
[Music]
a reduction in english scores of 0.09
standard deviations that's marginally
significant
you know that's suggestive but not
perhaps
particularly large
so these effects are not not not
particularly large in particular in
aggregate so if you aggregate everything
together
there don't seem to be any uh
significant effects
so perhaps the english scores are
suggestive
but sort of not particularly large there
are some mild effects on discipline
interestingly there's an increase in
swearing you think that's good or bad
you can think about that um but sort of
there seems to be a little bit of effect
of of
like in terms of like language uses use
usage
uh there's no effects on violent and
disruptive behavior which you might
think is like
a lot more damaging potentially
okay so just summarizing what does the
paper find well having
poor classmates makes wealthy students
more pro-social and generous
they're more likely to volunteer for
charities
i didn't show you that evidence but
that's another piece of evidence that he
finds
they're more likely to give in money and
dictator games to give more
higher fractions of their shared in
dictator games
they also choose more equitable
outcomes and sort of disinterested
third-party games where essentially you
choose between two other
students and their allocation so it's
not just that they're more
likely to willing to give up money that
others get but also they're more likely
to choose equal allocations
in third-party games and disinterested
games again i didn't show you that
evidence but it seems to be
that what's increasing here is sort of
like inequality aversion
um and these sort of disinterested um uh
uh uh dictator or other types of games
where essentially um these students by
being exposed to poor kids
are now more averse against
unequal outcomes in these types of games
second there is like less discrimination
and more higher willingness to socialize
with the poor
they're more likely to choose poor
teammates
in sports contests they're also more
willing to attend play dates with poor
children again i didn't
show you that evidence and then there's
like some small negative effects on
academic
outcomes that i think are mostly
negligible
now there's an other work on the contact
hypothesis which i showed you so the
contact what is the contact hypothesis
the contact hypothesis is from uh goes
back to at least
alport in 1954 which is the idea that
interpersonal contacts reduces prejudice
until certain conditions and not just
prejudice but also
changes attitudes and social preferences
potentially
so matt lowe who is a phd student here
at mit has a very nice paper that looks
at
cricket tournaments and asks the
question whether cricket leagues in
india
can increase cross-cast interaction and
pro-sociality so what he does is he
randomizes
uh essentially cricket leaks and teams
and cricket leaks
where people across different casts are
now more or less likely to play with
each other
both in terms of like um he varies or
there's variation in the study
within teams so are you more or less
likely to have
a or people some people are more or less
likely to have a
lower higher caste a person from a
different cast
in their team and he has um variation in
what he calls
adversarial contact which is like
they're more or less likely to be
exposed to
uh uh players from other teams uh
uh in higher different casts from
themselves right so if you're on the
team
and have like a person from a different
cast on your team
you're on the same team you share the
same objective and you want to win
together so now be having somebody from
a different task or just somebody who's
different in various ways in your team
might like might uh make you like them
better you might be sort of more
positive about them
um uh you might be sort of more likely
to talk to them
you might learn about them you might
sort of see some sides in them that you
hadn't seen before
so you might be more likely to empathize
and look at sort of nice characteristics
of them
and sort of update them positively about
people from other tasks
and that changes your attitudes towards
them in general
if however you play against somebody
from different casts
you might actually that might actually
if anything backfire because you know
you really
don't like your opponents you might see
them very negatively you might be
aggressive towards them you might be
unfriendly towards them
you might sort of um not like it that
they win against you or the like
so um this ad these adversarial
interactions might actually
backfire in the sense that they might
not foster integration but actually sort
of
uh make things um uh uh worse
so um matt runs this experiment and
finds
evidence of increased cross-cast
interactions so people are more likely
to
be friends more likely to hang out with
others they also
are more generous in dictator and other
types of games
they're also more likely to engage and
trade um
or in economic exchange so much what
matt does is sort of he randomizes
gloves there's like left
left gloves and right gloves and he has
the same for flip-flops left flip-flops
and right flip-flops
and people are more likely to trade with
somebody from another cast
if they have been uh on the same team
with people from other class if they
have a higher fraction of people on
their
uh uh on their team of people from other
casts
they're more likely to engage in all
these behaviors they're more likely to
have cross-cast interaction more likely
to be pro-social
more likely to engage in economic
exchange with people from other
casts so that's all true for
um a collaborative contact that is to
say that it's contact with people
uh on the same team in contrast for
adversarial interactions when people are
in the opposite team
having more people from other casts are
being exposed to more people from other
casts
uh does not have these positive effects
and for some of these outcomes have even
negative effects
so if anything it sort of backfires it
doesn't just
just a mere exposure to others if you
were sort of in an adversarial contact
situation
does not really foster uh pro-sociality
or any of these
types of integration if anything it
backfires
now why is that important when you think
about like for example attitudes towards
immigrants
um it really matters hugely what types
of contacts people are exposed to
if people work together in the same team
if they have perhaps like team pay
if they want to like work towards the
same goal
really that can it seems this evidence
suggests can foster pro-sociology
uh and so on and so forth that leads to
integration
reduced discrimination and so on and so
forth so if sort of the incentives are
aligned or if we could sort of set up
incentives that are aligned
people might become nicer to each other
and
interactions might be fostered in
contrast if contact is adversarial
if you're worried that immigrants are
taking away your jobs or like
being exposed to immigrants might just
do the opposite right so you might see a
lot of immigrants
but in a way if you feel like you're in
competition with them if they're
adversarial if they're sort of you're
your enemies in some ways or your
opponents and like some competition for
a job
being exposed to them might things in
fact if anything
uh uh uh uh worse
um finally there's a another piece of
very nice uh
evidence by corn oidal this is um papers
considering the
impact of random interracial
interactions among college roommates
um in south africa on stereotypes
attitudes and performance so what they
look at essentially
is roommates of different race um
reduces so these are black and white
students reduces
white students stereotypes towards
blacks and increases interracial
friendships it also improves grades and
lowers dropouts among blacks so there's
sort of a number of positive effects
of a very simple policy of like
increasing contacts among roommates and
again if you think about this evidence
it seems to suggest that perhaps that's
kind of like if you have a roommate
that you're going to live with for quite
a while that feels a lot like
collaborative contact in the sense of
like you're sort of stuck with that
roommate for quite a while
so you might as well sort of make the
best out of it even if you initially
don't like that person
and you have the same objectives of
being happy together living together
and that really seems to foster and have
some positive
benefits
so taking together that sort of says um
so a you know the contact hypothesis
seems to be broadly right
uh contact to people who are different
from you um
uh might make you more tolerant or more
pro-social
towards them there might be more sort of
integration of different groups
but what really seems to matter quite a
bit is the type of contact that people
are
exposed to okay so finally
and relatively quickly i'll tell you a
little bit about whether people
underestimate the benefits of
post-sociality i should mention that
problem set three question two is in
fact
trying to ask you to do something
related to that so you might want to
actually do the problems at first before
you finish this lecture
uh at least sort of sorry not the entire
problem set but like question two
of problem set three um that will not
take you
very long um um uh to do so and it's
more like a fun
exercise that i thought would be nice
for you to uh to engage in
but anyway um this is a very nice paper
by
kumar and epley so that's a typo here i
should say
kumar neplay and the authors asked the
question about
do we have correct beliefs about the
impacts of generosity
and so what's the underlying reason here
is well many pro-social acts require
estimating the impacts on the recipient
but if you give money to somebody in
africa if you
help anybody any people in need if you
donate money in general if you
like write letters of gratitude or if
you do random acts of kindness
it requires some sort of estimation of
how is the other person going to feel
if they receive uh if they're on the
receiving end of this pro-social act
now what eppley and kumar argue is
people are
subject to egocentric bias which may
lead them
to systematically underestimate the
positive impacts of pro-sociology in
this case
gratitude letters and so why is that
well it's because predicting others
mental states is different
difficult it's really hard to um
for people to understand how another
person might feel
usually people would sort of think about
themselves and sort of think about how
would i feel and then what
what would things be and how are things
like and and it's very hard to
understand
uh how others might react to you
it sort of requires perspective taking
and that's sometimes
tricky for people um to do so this is
again um a very nice experiment by um
kumar and nicolas apley not
not nicolas last name but nick appley
and they test whether people
misunderstand the cause
the consequences of showing appreciation
and so what are these
experiments there's a series of
experiments that look at this what do
they look like
but what what they do is like they ask
people uh
mba students or subjects and expert
subjects and experiments
to pick a pro-social act that's writing
a gratitude letter for example
and then ask how the giver and the
recipient will be affected
in some cases only the recipient in some
cases also
the giver then they perform the
pro-social act
by for example writing a letter of
gratitude and then assess how the giver
and the recipients were actually
affected by
doing that and then you can compare that
to item number two to the estimation
ex-ante now what do they find
they find uh clear evidence that when
you look at like in particular when you
look at the giver
so these um graphs all show kind of like
the predicted
uh ratings the ratings is between zero
and ten um
about like um how um uh what's the
experience how happy is the other person
uh what is the surprise about receiving
um
uh this letter of gratitude in this
example so people are more surprised
than predicted
they're also more surprised about the
content than pre
predicted um they also uh the
recipient's mood is actually
better than predicted and uh the
awkwardness is also
um better than predicted so when you ask
people to write like letters of
gratitude
people tend to say oh you know like uh
it's going to be like tedious to do
and like um the other person might feel
it's
awkward and what am i going to say and
is it going to be weird what i'm going
to say
is the person they do don't they know
already anyway that i'm
really appreciate off that person and so
on so um
people come up with all sorts of reasons
why they might not want to do that
if you sort of introspect and ask
yourself how many letters of gratitude
have you written in the last year
that doesn't few people actually do that
in practice
and perhaps some of these reasons like
the perceived awkwardness or perhaps
sort of the underestimation of
the recipient's mood might contribute to
that now if you also think for a little
bit like
uh how would one actually feel to
receive these letters it's pretty
obvious once you think about it that
most people are actually quite happy
about receiving such letters it's kind
of nice if somebody
tells you look you did something really
nice for me sometime
like a long time ago and you know this
helped me a lot in my career and
whatever ways or like in
in getting into school into like college
or whatever it might be
it's really nice to sort of hear from
somebody that um you did something nice
in their life
that people are quite um uh happy about
now what sort of like um some evidence
uh
some summary of that well so we tend to
systematically underestimate
others appreciations in expressions of
gratitude
that's also true for some other types of
effects that tends to be also true for
like
random acts of kindness people tend to
be surprisingly more
happy about those compared to predicted
it's also true so apple and schroeder
argue um
for social connections so people also
underestimate on average
how they themselves and other feel when
starting conversations so what this
experiment does is it gets people to
adrenalize as people to
start conversations during commuting on
buses or trains
and once people start doing that again
before when you ask them like you know
how is the other person going to feel
how are you going to feel and so on
people will say well it's gonna be
awkward and like what are we gonna talk
about
and is the other person even interested
and so on um but once you actually do
that people
seem to be quite happy to have started
conversations so making human um
connection to be clear not everybody is
happy some people might be also grumpy
but the vast majority at least in these
types of study
seem to be quite happy about uh
initiating social contact
about uh expressions letters of
gratitude uh
or things like random acts of kindness
it's really nice if somebody happens to
be something to do something nice
towards you it could be like a random
person who you've never
seen before and you never see again just
some random person on the street is
really nice to you
that might make you day it could be also
somebody who
um you know quite well and he's a good
friend and uh uh
who just wants to do something nice uh
for you for no good apparent reasons
so one caveat to these kinds of
experiments is these are very much like
one short
one short short interactions these are
one-time interactions and then the
effects are measured
so there are some questions about do
these effects persist for repeat
interactions
that is to say like maybe if you do that
once people are quite happy
but when you try it more often these
effects tend to go away
so there's a bit of a question kind of
like how persistent how important are
these in practice if you do that more
often
in particular in the long run and then
another
important question here is then the
question about is are we
under investing in pro-sociality in
terms of our behavior
so lots of people who tend to be quite
um
selfish and sort of do good things for
themselves and not so much for others
presumably they do that because they
want to make themselves happy presumably
people who do nice things towards others
to some degree
do that because they want to make the
other person happy in part perhaps
because because of social image and
self-image concerns but one important
hypothesis that eppley and others
raises the question of like well i'll be
underestimating
how good it might not only make others
feel but also ourselves feel from being
nice
that is to say perhaps one easy way of
making ourselves happy
is not just by being selfish and
maximizing whatever
outcomes we get but be really being nice
towards others
in part perhaps because it just makes us
happy to see when others are happy
perhaps it makes us happy because you
know others will be the nicer toss
and there's a question about can we make
others and
ourselves happier by being more
pro-social
perhaps um because we underestimate uh
uh to start with
uh what these effects um might be uh i
don't think there's that much evidence
on on this specific question but i'd
love to uh learn more and when you think
about like your own life
you might wanna experiment uh uh for a
while and seeing like
um trying to be nicer trying to uh uh
engage in random acts of kindness
letters of gratitude
and gratitude and so on that might be a
nice habit to acquire
and you might see it might may and might
make you uh happier
surely it will make the other person on
the receiving end happier
okay so let me sort of summarize what we
learned
what we studied on social preferences so
first others outcomes and utility matter
for people's choices quite a bit
so in their situation essentially people
are willing to give to others and
they're influenced by others
in their choices now upon closer look
there's not much evidence of pure
altruism rarely does it seem that people
just do stuff for others
just for the sake of others doing well
and that is to say like if people get
the chance of like
hiding their not so nice actions they
will often take advantage of that
the motivation there often is uh instead
motivation to give to others or be nice
to others to be pro-social
is often saving face in front of others
this is social image
or themselves which is um self-image
so here are so and because of that
situational circumstances matter greatly
societal norms are
are really important to consider so when
you think about like incentives or any
sort of types of structures and
organizations
how might you um set incentives or how
might we sort of
structure certain groups or people
working together
understanding these norms and
circumstances is key for fostering
pro-sociology
if you want people to be nice to each
other you have to set it up in a way
that it's maybe um
observable what people do it's
encouraged there's
opportunities for reciprocity and so on
so a lot of the design of society of
like a firm of a group that you work in
or a team that you work in really seems
to matter
so on the one hand as i said before it's
a little bit disappointing that there's
not much
pure altruism but on the other hand if
you sort of understand
the motivations poor for people being to
engage in
acts that are good for others we can
sort of design
uh incentives and structures that people
work in accordingly
which will then create people being
friendly and cooperative
to each other second i showed you that
social preferences matter at workplaces
um relative pay can depress incentives
to work
this is the evidence by banjera the
fruit pickers that i showed you
pay inequality can lower performance by
reduced morale so like in particular
pay inequality is uh seemingly
unjustified
that's really bad for worker morale and
might might lower
our worker outputs and sort of
attendance and so on
third social preferences appear to be
malleable
and shaped by uh external factors
in particular um there's evidence in
favor of the
contact hypothesis being exposed to
others from different backgrounds really
seems to uh
make us more tolerant and more
understanding more pro-social
towards these other groups but also more
pro-social perhaps
in general which is the the evidence by
gautam rao
and then finally there's some evidence
that bias beliefs may
lower pro-sociality in a sense that like
people might under
invest potentially in how nice they are
to others
perhaps because they misunderstand what
the effect of
engaging in such pro-social act might
have on others
and so potentially correcting these
beliefs or experimenting
might sort of increase pro-sociality at
least in some
settings now um what's coming next what
are the next lectures lecture number 14
is about
limited attention 15 is about projection
and attribution bias
this is the idea that people have
trouble
projecting how they might feel in
different states of the world
that is the idea if you're really hungry
it's really hard to project how you
might feel when you're not hungry and
vice versa
we're going to look at that and lecture
16 and 17 we'll look
more specifically about beliefs and
learning we talked a little bit about
beliefs already in various ways
but they're now we're going to talk
specifically about like biases and
beliefs and
learning as in like people um uh uh
suboptimally learning perhaps because of
um computational issues in a sense
that's really hard to learn in some
settings in part because of motivated
beliefs
people might be uh drive utility from
their beliefs
as in for example i might want to think
that i'm a good-looking smart
and a good teacher and if
i get feedback on one way or the other i
might react to
positive feedback a lot more i might
sort of update positively if somebody
says frank you're really smart i might
sort of update positively
because i feel really good about it if
somebody says and said frank you're not
so smart i might mostly ignore that
feedback
because um it might make me feel bad
about
myself so that's all for now thank you
so much
you